das tagesgespräch bei phoenix heute mit
boris palmer dem grünen
oberbürgermeister von tübingen
grüßen sie in ihrer wohnung sind sie
zufrieden mit dem was da gestern beim
gipfel rausgekommen sind einverstanden
vielleicht sogar einzustellen jahr den
märkten nicht herauskommen es kann nur
der impfstoff verteilt werden der auch
produziert wird und dass ich da jetzt
googelt das war klar
am anfang hat man einfach zu wenig von
den impfstoffen wo liegt die schuld
ihrer meinung nach weiß ich nicht
interessiert mich auch nicht da wäre ich
jetzt er bei markus söder aber es nützt
uns das da über fehler der vergangenheit
zu diskutieren ich sehe klar dass
staaten die einfach rigoros auf sich
selbst geachtet haben und bestellt haben
wir das zeug hält also israel usa
großbritannien dass die viel besser
dastehen weil sie mehr impfstoff haben
und wir sind jetzt sozusagen der
europäischen solidarität gemeinsam
schlechter gestellt das ist
wahrscheinlich unbefriedigend ärgerlich
auch man würde sich wünschen dass es
anders gelaufen wäre aber man kann die
vergangenheit nicht ändern
das klingt gut und verständnisvoll ihre
parteichef robert habeck ist da gar
nicht so verständnisvoll gesagt der
staat muss eingreifen
da muss ich nicht jeden tag etwas neues
erzählen lassen von der industrie was
sagen sie als oberbürgermeister der
stadt in der die neue impfstoff dann
wirklich überhaupt erfunden wurde vor 20
jahren wurde korrekt gegründet und jetzt
ist es der erfolgreiche wirksamste im
stoff die impfstoff klasse m rna
wie kann ich ihn sicher sagen dass die
kobik alles tun dass die schon vor ort
produziert wenn man jetzt politisch
eingreifen will dann sollte man die
frage dazu dass du noch mal anschauen
also ich kann zum beispiel nicht
verstehen was die kanzlerin sagt dass
wir jetzt da was davon haben dass wir
keine nur zulassung hatten sondern eine
vorläufige zulassung
dadurch waren die briten vier wochen
schneller und ich würde dafür plädieren
dass der tierwelt impfstoffen und
zulassung bekommt dann haben wir in vier
oder sechs wochen früher zunehmend zur
verfügung
der ist genauso sicher der ist
durchgetestet er ist mit sicherheit
nicht viel schlechter
vielleicht sogar besser als dabei und
werkstoff als die gleiche technologie
ist ich würde das risiko eingehen und
sagen
haben wir notstand gesetzgebung man sich
das mal genauer anguckt dann kann man
sich auch mal den neuzulassungen von dem
stoff leisten außerdem ist es nach vorne
geblickt das bringt uns mehr impfstoff
das ist meine botschaft
jetzt reden wir mal über das wie sich
das bei ihnen im alltag darstellt wir
hören ja schon aus den verschiedenen
landkreisen und wahlkreisen vor allen
dingen auch dass da der druck steigt die
leute wollen natürlich raus aus dem lot
dauern aber wir müssen auch erst mal
impfen
wie läuft das denn also der der staat
sitzt ganz oben drauf dann die
bundesländer und dann vielleicht noch
die landkreise und kommunen klappt das
dann mit dementen einigermaßen zumindest
bei ihnen also die organisation vor ort
bei uns sogar wir haben das größte im
zentrum in baden württemberg mit 18
impfstraßen können leider nur drei
betreiben gibt eines impfstoffs ist
unser problem aber bekommen sehr viele
briefe von den älteren leuten oder ihren
angehörigen design es ist super
organisiert wir werden freundlich
behandelt in gewinnen gibt sogar
kostenfreie taxifahrten bis zum ins
zentrum
daher glaube ich kein problem der
organisation läuft es geht nur um die
verteilung des impfstoffs dann gibt es
immer wieder auch kritik daran dass sagt
zum beispiel auch der grünen chef robert
habeck dass die menschen in
telefonschleifen hängen
vor allen dingen jetzt auch die die
älteren und sehr viel älteren menschen
um sich termine zu beschaffen und das
ein riesenproblem ist sind sie auch
dafür das system zu ändern dass man von
unten das quasi beschickt also dass sie
briefe rausschicken und einladen wie
handgemacht wieviel rausgeschickt die
über 65-jährigen wir haben jetzt ist
einrichtungen geschaffen
der seniorenrat nimmt leute an die hand
die sich selber keinen impftermin mehr
besorgen können entsprechend
unterstützungsleistungen sind in
tübingen bereits auf dem weg weil es
alles nichts daran ändert dass man
keinen impftermin vergeben kann wenn der
impfstoff nicht da ist und diese absagen
wegen mangel dem impfstoff ist indes
wenig durcheinander bringt und die
knappheit führt dazu dass man halt lange
in diesen warteschleifen hängt und dann
doch nicht in termin kommt den man haben
möchte das kann man durch organisationen
aus meiner sicht nicht wesentlich ändern
die in deutschland ist immer die gleiche
krankheit kein termin und fokus auf
impfen derzeit der fokus auf testen
ist irgendwie schwächer geworden oder ja
ist halte ich für einen fehler
insbesondere was die schnelltests angeht
könnten wir noch sehr viel mehr machen
wir fangen jetzt in tübingen an die
öffnung der kitas und die öffnung der
schulen zumindest die abschlussklassen
dürfen ja weder präsenzunterricht haben
mit schnelltests zu begleiten
ich habe gerade erst heute eine
entscheidung getroffen dass über das
städtische budget zu finanzieren weil da
mal wieder die finanzierung nicht klappt
das ist für mich so ein déjà vu von
einem halben jahr habe verlangt dass
bund und länder die tests die
regelmäßigen tests für die altenheime
finanzieren wurde dauerhaft verweigert
und ist eigentlich jetzt zu haben doch
immer dann tatsächlich erlaubt worden
und jetzt haben wir das gleiche spiel
wieder dass die tests die schnelltests
für die schulen und kitas nicht
finanziert werden
zum glück haben gemeinderat der daher
verständlich ist und auch mutig werden
wir da auch wieder mit einem start hat
namhafte betrag in vorleistung gehen und
hoffen dass sich das bald bessert also
das heißt sie gehen einen neuen weg
genauso wie mit den altenheimen und
pflegeheimen jetzt für die schulen haben
sie den tests die zugelassen sind und
die das ganze leisten können
dr fat alle jemand die da nicht nur
selber aktiv ist oder auch exzellente
kontakte zu produzenten hat und sie hat
bereits erste bestellungen können neue
schnelltests kategorien auftrag gegeben
die nicht so tief eingeführt werden
müssen sodass auch es möglich ist dass
das kita-personal sich zum beispiel
gegenseitig diese tests abnimmt was uns
halt auf groß auffällt ist die
bürokratie in österreich gibt es tipps
zum selbermachen schon bei uns wird es
wieder einmal nicht zugelassen weil
irgendjemand meint es sei zu gefährlich
wir stehen uns da will ich auch oft
selbst im weg und in der pandemie kann
man sich das eigentlich nicht leisten
das ist ähnlich wie mit der zulassung
wir brauchen länger warten um den
anderen text auf einem zulassungs
dokument zu haben da wird ja gar nichts
mehr erforscht sondern werden nur die
unterlagen nochmal angeschaut
das sollten wir uns immer mehr trauen
ich finde zumindest wer sich so viel
traut bei der einschränkung von
grundrechten könnt ihr auch ein bisserl
abstriche machen
bei bürokratischen vorschriften oder
beim datenschutz ein paar mal zum
schluss noch eine kurze frage
denken sie schon und sie denken ja schon
über lockerungen nachher war so in
größeren und wie schaut es
beispielsweise aus mit friseuren
wie sie sehen ist bei mir ziemlich
schlechter ist dringend nötig dass der
friseur wieder aufmacht wir haben gerade
jetzt in der lokalzeitung gelesen dass
ein viertel etwa da handwerksbetrieben
das bisher in einem kurz vor der pleite
steht dass die hilfen nicht kommen da
sie zu niedrig sind dass auch die
gärtnereien jetzt ihre ganze früh raus
anzucht wahrscheinlich wegwerfen müssen
wenn ich bald auf gemacht werden können
sie jetzt potenzieren sie eben auch die
schäden je länger dann noch da und
anhält
wir haben hinter wegen jetzt schon zwei
wochen ziemlich stabil
eine inzidenz von unter 50 also
eigentlich die voraussetzungen eröffnung
erreicht und ich plädiere dafür dass man
das wohl dosiert mit hygiene konzepten
schritt für schritt tut
ich hätte es für richtig gehalten jetzt
auch mit den grundschulen anzufangen
aber meiner meinung nach können wir
jetzt nicht in nordeuropa plan verfolgen
oder den 0 coup planen und dann bis mai
alle im noch daran weiterwursteln das
wird zu viele schäden an
wirtschaftsgesellschaft psyche und auch
gesundheitssystem verursachen sondern
wir brauchen jetzt gute eröffnungs
konzepte schnelltests werden dabei
meiner meinung nach eine wichtige rolle
spielen warum sollte man nicht auch mal
an der ladentür hat schnelltest machen
und der cummins kaufhaus eine ganze
menge guter forderung von boris palmer
dem hobby von typen danke fürs gespräch
dagegen